We followed Anthony as he developed
skills from front end to back
end programming.
He's also explored
mobile programming and
data analysis through
building Project Compass.
Your next step is to analyze Project
Compass web app that Anthony's created
and identify which type of
programmer would build each feature.
This activity is meant to help you
evaluate your next step as a programmer.
Do you want to build out
front end features or
dive into back end architecture?
Would you want to create mobile
applications or analyze data?
After completing this activity
you'll be choosing the path that
most interests you.
Remember, you can always dive into
different areas of programming, but for
now let's figure out your next step.